Alright, alright, alright.
Uh, take up the whole screen- okay.
Okay, like this, right?
Uh, there you go.
Perfect.
That's perfect, right?
Oh, yeah, this is very, very spooky, baby.
I'm scared.
There you go, perfect.
I can fix it up!
Oh!
Look at that!
Push, pull, push, pull!
Okay, maybe I need to get my cat out of the way.
Can I jump off?
Oh, oh, wait, you can.
You can.
Oh, you can.
I thought that would be an invisible wall.
Wow.
Can I become a shoe?
I can become a shoe!
What
the fuck?
There's a fall damage here!
There's a fall damage!
Why the fuck is there fall damage?
Oh!
It was at this moment that he knew.
He fucked up.
Wait!
Stop!
Nice run.
Oh wait, you can sprint!
Why did no one tell me to sprint here?
I've been fucking walking this entire time.
You can sprint in this game.
Why is it here so tiny?
Look around by using, wow, by using arrow keys.
Oh shit.
I was like, oh shit.
Don't check under the bed.
Don't drink other pain!
Crying!
Yeah, little bitch.
Yeah, you little bitch.
I thought that hit me.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
I'm not spooked at all.
This is
ridiculous.
You're so smart!
Holy shit!
Look at...